>> THERE WERE SOME TALK THAT
WAS GOING ON.
>>> SO WE ARE GOING TO START
COOKING THAT UP.
WE HAVE FLIPPED THIS WAY JUMPED
IN AND ASSAYED DRAYMOND OVER 5
1/2 ASSISTS.
>> I LIKE IT.
I AM AN INTERESTED PARTY IN
THAT FIRST OF ALL, BEFORE I GET
MY COMMENTARY TOGETHER, I DON'T
WANT ANYONE TO FORGET THE MILK
DISCUSSIONS WE HAD LAST WEEK.
I GOT MY CHOCOLATE MILK READY.
I'M READY TO GET THIS.
LISTEN, I WAS IN THE LAB THIS
MORNING AND THE SIX ASSISTS I
THINK FORD DRAYMOND IS A REALLY
INTERESTING BET . I THINK THIS
GAME IS GOING TO BE PRETTY HIGH-
SCORING.
I THINK HE'S GOING TO BE A
REALLY BIG PART OF HOW THE
WARRIORS GET THEIR BUCKETS
TONIGHT.
THE ONLY THING THAT WORRIES ME,
AND GREG, YOU CAN TALK TO ME
ABOUT IT, FEEL LIKE THESE BIG
GAMES, SOME REASON HE ALWAYS
ENDS UP WITH TWO TECHNICAL
FOULS, SO WE JUST NEVER KNOW.
I DON'T WANT HIM TO GET POP IN
THIS GAME.
>> TRAY IS KNOWN FOR GETTING A
TECH OR TWO BUT I THINK WE
MIGHT BE ALL RIGHT.
WE MIGHT BE ALL RIGHT IN THIS
SITUATION, BRO.
>> I WILL SAY, TOO, THEY SAID 5
1/2.
HIS LINE A 6 1/2.
YOU CAN TAKE THE SIX-PLUS.
I ALSO WANT TO JUMP IN BECAUSE
WE ARE BRINGING UP MILK AGAIN
AND THERE IN 85 SAID SOMEBODY
GET MY BOY MIKE SOME AIR PODS
FOR CHRISTMAS AND RYAN SOME
MILK, PLEASE.
I'M NIPPING THIS IN THE BUD
RIGHT NOW.
I BROUGHT SOME MILK THIS WEEK,
SOME ALMOND MILK.
SO I'VE GOT TO SHAKE IT UP REAL
GOOD AND THEN WE ARE GOING TO
POUR IT OUT AND I'LL DRINK THE
MILK BECAUSE IT'S WHAT THE CHAT
WANTED.
SO I'LL POUR IT OUT AND DRINK
SOME MILK.
I DON'T LIKE THE WAY THAT
LOOKED WHEN IT CAME OUT.
>> THIS IS SUCH AN EPIC MOMENT.
>> LITERALLY DRINKING SOME
MILK.
>> WE REALLY FORCED RYAN TO
DRINK SOME MILK.
>> I DON'T WANT TO HEAR IT
ANYMORE.
I DRANK SOME MILK.
I GOT IN HERE, I POURED OUT
SOME ALMOND MILK.
I'M NOT A DAIRY GUY.
I'M NOT A MILK GUY.
>> YOU LOOK UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> I'M INCREDIBLY
UNCOMFORTABLE.
I DON'T DRINK MILK AT ALL.
BUT LET'S GET BACK.
SIX-PLUS IS 195.
WE COULD DO THAT.
LET'S SEE.
BLAKE SAID GET THAT FAKE MILK
OUT OF YOUR.
THAT'S NOT REAL MILK.
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
IT'S MILK.
>> THIS IS NEVER GOING TO END.
>> MILK IS MILK.
>> OH MY GOD, THIS IS SO GREAT.
THERE'S SO MUCH MILK TALK.
>> YOU CAN'T MILK A NUT.
>> THAT'S FUNNY, OH MY GOD.
WE'RE EVEN GOING THERE.
LET'S SEE.
GIANNIS OVER ON POINTS.
I'M ASSUMING HIS OVER/UNDER IS
LIKE 30.
>> LET'S SEE.
SOMEBODY DROP  IN HERE,  FOR
RENT SAID GIANNIS OVER 30.
LET'S SEE.
WHAT IS THIS?
>> ENOUGH WITH THE MILK.
I'M TRYING TO WIN RIGHT NOW.
>> HIS OVER/UNDER IS 31 1/2.
SO MINUS 160, LISTEN, GIANNIS
CAN GET 30 IN HIS SLEEP, I FEEL
LIKE, AS LONG AS HE'S MAKING
FREE THROWS HE'S GOING TO GET
VERY, VERY CLOSE TO THIS
NUMBER.
SO I DON'T HAVE ANY PROBLEM
MAKING THIS THE FIRST LEG.
I THINK THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO HAVE PLUS 30 AND A
LOT OF THEIR PARLAYS.
MAYBE THAT'S NOT A GOOD THING.
>> I LIKE THIS.
NO ONE ON THE WARRIORS CAN
GUARD GIANNIS .  IN MY OPINION.
I'M A WARRIOR FAN, DIEHARD.
>> THERE WE GO, GUYS.
GIANNIS 30-PLUS.
LET'S SEE, SOMEBODY JUST
DROPPED IN HERE, AND I LIKE
THIS BECAUSE WE CAN GO OVER TO
THE OTHER GAME.
DANTE KASHA SAID MARCUS SMART
OVER 11 1/2  POINTS.
>> WE'LL LEAN ON YOU FOR THIS
ONE.
YOUR WARRIORS, NOT THE
WARRIORS, THE CELTICS FAN.
>> YES SIR, VERY ANTI-WARRIORS.
DON'T SAY THAT, GREG.
IT'S A BAD SLIP-UP ON YOUR END.
I LIKE THIS ONE.
HERE IS WHAT I WILL SAY, AND
I'M GOING TO ASK FOR SOME
THUMBS UP AND THUMBS DOWN
BECAUSE I MAY WANT AN
ALTERATION HERE.
I KIND OF LIKE MARCUS SMART
THREES, LIKE HOLD ON, LET'S GO
OVER HERE, BECAUSE IT IS AT 11
1/2, IF I'M CORRECT.
IT'S 11 1/2.
WHAT IS THREE, 1 1/2?
>> HE IS TWO THREES.
HE DEFINITELY SHOOTS A LOT OF
THEM.
HE WAS IN A PARLAY THAT I
PLAYED A COUPLE DAYS AGO.
YOU'RE GOING TO GET THE VOLUME.
I THINK THIS IS ANOTHER GAME
THAT'S PROBABLY GOING TO BE
PRETTY HIGH SCORING IN THE END
OF IT BECAUSE I THINK THE
LAKERS WON'T BE ABLE TO GUARD
THE CELTICS FOR VERY LONG.
SO IF YOU GO TO TWO THREES,
WHAT'S THE VALUE ADDED?
WHAT'S THE NUMBER?
>> TWO THREES WOULD BE MINUS
150 AS OPPOSED TO GETTING AT
MINUS 158.
I ALSO THINK I LIKE HIM --
SORRY, GO AHEAD.
>> KEYS TWO -- HE'S HIT THAT
MARK IN 2 OF HIS LAST 4 GAMES,
SO IT'S A GAMBLE.
IT'S A GAMBLE.
>> WOULD YOU FEEL MORE
COMFORTABLE WITH THE POINT
TOTAL?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> AND I JUMPED IN HERE FOR A
SECOND?
BECAUSE WHILE WE ARE HERE, NOT
TO COMPLETELY GO AWAY FROM
MARCUS SMART, BUT WE'VE GOT TO
LISTEN TO EVERYBODY IN HERE.
J HARTMAN SAID JAYLEN BROWN TWO-
PLUS THREE-POINTERS IS A LOCK,
SAME WITH 20-PLUS POINTS.
I'M GOING TO IGNORE THE 20-PLUS
POINTS BECAUSE WE ARE HERE.
MINUS HUNDRED AS A LEG IS NOT
HORRIBLE.
WE HAVE DONE A LOT WORSE.
>> I LIKE THAT A LOT.
YOU'RE ADDING A LOT MORE
RELIABILITY IN TERMS OF THE --
NOT THE VOLUME, BUT THE
PERCENTAGE SHOOTER HERE.
THE VOLUME MATTERS AND I THINK
THE MARCUS SMART PLAY IS NOT A
BAD ONE, BUT I FEEL MUCH MORE
COMFORTABLE WITH JAIDEE OVER TWO
.
>> LET'S DO THAT.
AND THEN AND READ JUMPED IN
HERE AND SAID AL IS OUT
TONIGHT, Y'ALL.
DON'T FORGET.
AL HORFORD HAS BEEN OUT.
I THINK THE LAKERS WIN.
TATUM BEEN SLUMPING
OFFENSIVELY.
I DISAGREE.
I ACTUALLY DON'T THINK THAT
THERE IS A WORLD IN WHICH THE
CELTICS LOSE THREE STRAIGHT,
AND I THINK THE FACT THAT WE
CAN GET THEM AT MINUS 166 AND
THEN WE CAN START LAYING AROUND
WITH THE OTHER TWO LEGS, IF WE
WANT TO GO BACK TO THAT OTHER
GAME, I KIND OF LIKE THIS.
>> DID THE CELTICS PLAY LAST
NIGHT?
>> YES THEY DID.
THEY LOST TO THE CLIPPERS.
>> I DON'T KNOW, I DON'T LOVE
GAMES IN A BACK-TO-BACK. THE
LAKERS ARE PLAYING BETTER.
I DON'T THINK THE LAKERS ARE
VERY GOOD AT ALL.
THIS WOULD BE THE FIRST TIME WE
PUT A SIDE IN ONE OF THE GAMES,
OR ONE OF THE PARLAYS, SO I'M
NOT AGAINST IT.
I WILL JUMP INTO THE CHAT.
I THINK THE MARCUS SMART THING
WAS A GOOD AVOID.
WE SEE DARIAN SAYING IT'S A
TOUGH ONE, THE TRENCH GANGS
SAYING DON'T TAKE SMART FOR
NOTHING.
PLEASE SAYING LEAVE MARCUS
SMART OUT.
I THINK WE'RE ON THE RIGHT PATH
MOVING JB IN AND I DON'T KNOW,
YOU THINK HE'S GOING TO BE ABLE
TO CONVINCE US TO TAKE THE
CELTICS?
KIND OF IFFY.
>> THIS ISN'T RYAN'S PARLAY.
THIS ISN'T MY PARLAY.
INDEED, THIS ISN'T EVEN YOUR
PARLAY.
THIS IS THE PEOPLE'S PARLAY.
SO WE HAVE TO ASK THE PEOPLE,
IF WE GET A THUMBS UP, THUMBS
DOWN.
>> HAND UP FOR ME.
HOLD ON.
>> I SEE, THOUGH, I SEE IN THE
COMMENTS A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
TALKING ABOUT A D. IC DARIAN
85, HE SAYS A/D OVER ON
REDOUNDS.
WE NEED A D ON THE TICKET.
I ALSO SEE FLIP DOLLAR 23,
ANTHONY DAVIS ON POINTS.
DON'T SLEEP ON HIM.
>> IF WE WANT TO DO RECALL, WE
ALMOST PUT AN A/D IN THE LAST
ONE AND IT GOT SICK WITHIN
THREE MINUTES OF THE GAME.
NOT SAYING THAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN AGAIN, BUT I'M ALWAYS
WARY OF A/D.
I THINK THE REBOUNDS IN THIS
GAME PROBABLY MAKES MORE SENSE
THAN HIS POINTS, BUT I DON'T
KNOW.
I'LL LEAVE IT UP TO YOU GUYS
WHICH WAY YOU GUYS WANT TO
LEAN.
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW.
>> RYAN, WHAT ABOUT THIS ONE?
WHAT ABOUT THIS ONE, MY BAD,
BUT I SEE JACK CAMP SAYS SMART
FOUR-PLUS ASSIST IS A LOCK.
>> I LOVE IT
>> I LIKE MARCUS SMART MORE
DISHING THE BALL THEN SHOOTING
THREES AND SCORING POINTS.
I JUST FEEL MORE COMFORTABLE,
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
>> YEAH, I WILL SAY --
>> IS THAT HIM RIGHT THERE,
MINUS 13.
>> MINUS 1350.
I LOVE MY GUY JACK.
HE'S IN EVERY ONE OF THESE
SHOWS ANY BLOCKS IN HERE.
MINUS 1350, LET'S SEE WHAT THAT
WOULD DO.
LET'S SEE WHAT THAT WOULD DO.
NO, NO THANKS.
THANK YOU FOR DROPPING THE LIVE
BETS.
>> WHAT'S HIS LINE?
LET'S TALK ABOUT HIS ASSIST
TOTALS.
>> I WAS THINKING ABOUT
BRINGING THAT UP.
IT'S AT 6 1/2.
I ALSO LIKE MARCUS SMART TO
SOME OUT.
I WOULDN'T BE AGAINST TAKING
SIX, I'LL BE HONEST.
MINUS 260 AGAIN, WE'VE BEEN
TAKING A LITTLE BIT OF CHALK
HERE AND IT STILL DOESN'T GET
IS A PLUS 200.
I DON'T KNOW, I WILL SAY THIS
-- THE CHAT KEEPS DROPPING ZION
AND EMBIID PROPAGANDA.
NBA ON TNT GAMES, NBA ON TNT
GAMES.
>> WE ARE JUST TRYING TO ENSURE
THAT YOU GUYS GET YOUR MONEY
BACK IN CASE YOU LOSE.
>> YES, WHICH WE WON'T, BUT IN
CASE WE DO.
SO --
>> WHAT ABOUT AR 15?
I JUST SAW THAT.
WHAT ABOUT AR 15?
LAST TIME WE HAD HIM ON THE
TICKET HE HITS.
I'M JUST SAYING.
>> HE DID. I DID LIKE THAT.
>> I'M JUST SAYING, AR 15,
CELTICS ON THE BACK TO BACK.
>> MY MAN IS BECOMING LIKE A
LOW-KEY FOLK HERO THERE.
HE WAS INTERACTING WITH SOME OF
THE GIRLS COURTSIDE.
HE'S COMING INTO HIS OWN.
I KIND OF LIKE IT.
WHAT'S HIS POINTS AT?
>> CAN WE TAKE A LOOK?
>> 8 1/2.
>> 8 1/2 POINTS, THAT'S IT?
WHAT IS IT TO ADD 10 IN THERE?
NOW WE'RE TALKING.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT THE CHAT
THINKS.
IS THE CHAT ABOUT AUSTIN REESE?
I SEE SOME RONNIE WALKER.
>> I LIKE LONNIE WALKER.
I'LL TAKE LONNIE WALKER.
>> I LIKE LONNIE WALKER, TOO.
BUT MY GUY, HE HAD NINE POINTS,
25 POINTS, 10 POINTS IN HIS
LAST THREE GAMES.
MY MAN HAS BEEN GOING OVER THAT
8 1/2 MARK.
THAT'S WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
>> I KNOW, BUT YOU SEE A GUY
WHO SCORED 25 RECENTLY AND HIS
POINT TOTALS AT 8 1/2, DOES
THAT NOT FEEL LIKE -- YOU'RE
ACTUALLY DRINKING MILK RIGHT
NOW.
DOES THAT NOT FEEL LIKE BAIT,
RIGHT?
IT FEELS LIKE I'M BEING PUT ON
A HOOK RIGHT NOW.
>> RYAN, I MEAN YOU ARE ENTITLED
TO FEEL HOW YOU WANT TO FEEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
>> FOR SURE, ALWAYS.
>> BUT IF YOU DO, YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE MAN OF THE
PEOPLE, LOOKING INTO THE CHAT.
>> I AM, I BROUGHT UP LONNIE
WALKER.
>> YOU WOULD SEE A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT AR 15
AND THEY LIKE US BRINGING UP AR
15 AND ROCKING WITH ONE OF HIS
PROPS.
>> FRESH PRINCE CALLED IT THE
LOCK OF THE YEAR.
>> DO YOU FEEL LIKE YOUR
STRATEGY OF GOING TO CHECK HIS
THREES OVER THE POINTS IS A
BETTER PLAY?
BECAUSE I'M SAYING HERE, CLEVE
15 SAYING AUSTIN READS OVER TWO
FREEZE.
SO IF YOU ARE WORRIED ABOUT THE
HOOK, WE ONLY NEED SIX POINTS.
>> COULD BE FUN.
>> BUT WHY ARE WE THINKING SO
HARD, BRO?
AR 15, I THINK THIS ONE, IT'S
EASY.
8 1/2?
>> 8 1/2, SO WE ARE NOT DOING
THE 10.
WE ARE DOING 8 1/2.
>> WHAT'S THE 10?
LET'S TALK ABOUT IT.
>> THIS IS WHERE WE START
GETTING IN TROUBLE.
NO, NO, NO, BECAUSE THE 10 GOT
US TO PLUS THREE WHATEVER, THIS
IS STILL PLUS 300.
LET'S DO THIS.
>> OKAY, LET'S DO IT.
>> AND WE GO BACK TO THE OTHER
GAME?
I'M GETTING TOO MUCH
CELTICS/LAKERS.
I DON'T WANT TO BE UP UNTIL
MIDNIGHT WATCHING OUR PARLAY.
>> I'LL STAY OUT OF THAT.
AS LONG AS IT MEANS WE ARE
WINNING MONEY, I'LL STAY UP ALL
NIGHT.
>> THAT'S WHY YOU'VE GOT TO
COME TO THE WEST COAST, IT'S
THE BEST COAST.
YOU AIN'T GOT TO STAY UP ALL
LATE WATCHING GAMES.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
YOU CAN STILL WATCH THE GAMES
AT A REASONABLE TIME AND DO
WHAT YOU NEED TO DO AFTER THE
GAME, WEST COAST, WEST COAST.
BUT ANYWAY, WE ARE PLUS 300.
WE'VE GOT THREE PICS AND WE
NEED TWO MORE.
I'M BACK IN THE COMMENTS
BECAUSE I SEE A LOT OF PEOPLE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE IN HERE,
TALKING ABOUT YOUR BOY THAT YOU
JUST MENTIONED, MONTY WALKER.
BUT YOU WANT TO GO TO THE OTHER
GAME, THOUGH.
>> I'M LOOKING AT OTHER
COMMENTS, AS WELL, AND I'M
GOING -- I'LL BRING THIS UP TO
YOU GUYS BECAUSE WE HAVE TRUST
ISSUES WITH THIS MAN,
PARTICULARLY.
J McCULLOUGH 22 SAYS KLAY
THOMPSON, 20-PLUS POINTS.
>> I'M NOT IN.
>> WE HAVE A LIST. I HAVE TO
START BRINGING IN THE LIST,
I'LL PUT IT BEHIND ME.
IT'S CALLED THE BAND LIST AND
KLAY THOMPSON IS NUMBER ONE ON
THAT LIST.
>> NOT TODAY.
NOT TODAY, WE ARE NOT READY FOR
THAT ONE.
>> NOT TODAY.
NO WAY.
>> MIDDLETON, THOUGH.
>> KHRIS MIDDLETON, I SEE THAT.
FLIP DOLLARS AND KHRIS
MIDDLETON 15-PLUS AND HE SAID,
AND KLAY THOMPSON OVER POINTS
AGAIN.
>> I'M NOT FEELING THE CLAY BUT
KHRIS MIDDLETON TO GO GET 15?
I LIKE THAT.
>> WHO'S THE PRIMARY DEFENDER
FOR THE WING?
IS IT GOING TO BE OKAY?
IS OKAY GOING TO HAVE TO CHECK
CHRIS?
>> SHOULD BE ANDREW WIGGINS.
>> SO A PRETTY DECENT DEFENDER,
I WOULD SAY.
>> 15 SHOULD BE LIKE LAYUP
TERRITORY.
THERE IT IS MINUS 950.
>> THAT'S MINUS ONE.
>> I WAS TRYING TO TEASE HIM
ALL THE WAY DOWN TO 10 POINTS.
I'M NERVOUS ABOUT THIS ONE.
HIS LINE IS AT 16 1/2.
WE ARE BASICALLY TAKING HIS
OVER.
>> I THINK, NOT REALLY.
WITH THE POINT AND A HOOK --
>> I WAS TOLD LAST WEEK THAT WE
COULDN'T BUY IT DOWN A POINTS
BECAUSE --
>> NO, IT WAS A HALF POINTS,
MAN.
A POINT AND A HALF IS A BIG
DIFFERENCE.
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S THAT BIG
A DIFFERENCE.
>> WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE
MONEY, IT IS.
LET'S SEE.
PUT IT IN THERE FOR 15 AND
LET'S SEE WHAT WE GET AT MINUS
155.
>> IS GOING TO JUMP, IT'S GOING
TO BE GOOD.
>> THE WARRIORS, THEY PLAY
DECENT DEFENSE BUT THEY'RE NOT
JUST LIKE LOCKDOWN --
>> SCOOPS.
SCOOPS ALERTS.
AND RED THE WIGS OUT.
WIGGINS IS HURT.
WIGGINS OUT, WIGGINS OUT.
>> I LIKE THIS EVEN MORE NOW.
>> WE GET THIS OUT.
>> TWO-WAY IS OUT.
THE PEOPLE, THAT'S WHY WE NEED
YOU GUYS.
YOU INFORM US AND WE'RE IN THIS
TOGETHER.
WE ARE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER.
THEY GAVE US A SCOOP.
WIGGINS IS OUT. WHO'S THE
DEFENDER THAT'S GOING TO BE
GUARDING MIDDLETON?
>> IF IT'S JORDAN POOL HE'S
GOING TO HAVE 55 POINTS.
>> THAT'S BARBECUE CHICKEN.
KLAY THOMPSON.
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
>> IT'S KLAY THOMPSON.
CLAY MAC IS ALL RIGHT BUT YOU
KNOW HE'S NOT MOVING LIKE HE
USED TO.
>> ARE WE NOT CONCERNED THAT WE
BASICALLY TOOK THE OVER FOR
GIANNIS AND KHRIS MIDDLETON?
>> NOT REALLY.
>> THAT'S A GREAT POINT.
>> I'M NOT NECESSARILY.
WHAT REALLY WORRIES ME IS FRESH
PRINCE SAYS CHRIS LEFT LAST
GAME WITH A SPRAINED ANKLE.
NO PLAY.
>> THAT'S A GREAT POINT.
>> I MAKE THEM PRETTY
CONSISTENTLY.
>> DEBATABLE.
VERY DEBATABLE.
WHAT'S STEPH CURRY?
LET'S LOOK AT STEPH CURRY.
WHAT'S STEPH CURRY GOT GOING
ON?
>> IT'S 28 1/2.
AT THIS RATE, IF WE ARE GOING
TO KEEP TAKING THESE OVERS, WE
MAY AS WELL TAKE THE GAME OVER.
>> RISKY REESE SAYING CURRY
FIVE-PLUS THREES, HE SHOWS UP
TODAY, EASY.
FIVE THREES SEEMS LIKE A LOT
BUT IT'S STEPH CURRY, GREATEST
SHOOTER OF ALL TIME.
>> WEIGHT, SO LOOK, IF THE
PEOPLE IS TELLING US NOT TO
TRUST KHRIS MIDDLETON, DOES
THAT MEAN WE TAKE THE UNDER?
>> THIS WOULD BE THE FIRST TIME
WE'VE TAKEN AN UNDER ON THIS
SHOW.
>> THERE WHEEZY IS FUNNY.
HE SAID HE DON'T TRUST CHRIS.
THE FIRST TIME FOR EVERYTHING.
>> LOCALS PERM SAID GIANNIS
DOUBLE-DOUBLE.
>> CAN WE EVEN PUT THAT ON AIR?
IF WE CAN, I DO LIKE THAT.
>> NOPE, WE CAN'T.
THAT WAS --
>> NOT A SAINT GAME PARLAY.
>> THAT'S ON ME.
>> THAT'S ALL RIGHT.
I DIDN'T KNOW, EITHER.
>> WE ARE GOOD.
RISKY READ WITH THE CURRY FIVE-
PLUS THREES.
THAT'S A LOT OF THREES.
>> THAT IS A LOT OF FREEZE.
HOW ABOUT FOUR THREES?
>> J HERNANDEZ SAID GIANNIS
OVER  25 IF ANYTHING.
WHAT DO WE HAVE IN HERE THAT'S
JOLTING THIS UP?
>> WHAT'S WESTBROOK THREE POINT
TOTAL? RUSSELL WESTBROOK.
>> RUSSELL WESTBROOK?
RUSSELL WESTBROOK, DID YOU SAY
RUSSELL WESTBROOK?
>> BRODY WESTBROOK.
BRODY WESTBROOK THREES IS LOCK
OF THE YEAR.
>> WHO SAID THAT?
WHO SAID THAT?
UNDER, UNDER.
>> IN RED 257, UNDER.
>> OKAY, YOU GOT ME FIRED UP
FOR A SECOND.
I KNOW WE ARE TAKING ANOTHER
WESTBROOK OVER.
>> HE IS A BRICK LAYER BUT HE
CAN'T SHOOT THREES.
>> HE'S A BRICKLAYER AND WE
TOOK HIS ASSISTANT LAST WEEK,
AND HE DIDN'T PASS THE BALL.
>> YIKES.
LET'S SEE WHAT IT IS.
HALF.
>> OH MY GOD, HE CAN'T -- IT'S
JUST OVER ONE.
OH MAN.
SO IT'S LIKE, ARE WE GOING TO
-- HOW ARE WE FEELING ABOUT
THIS ONE?
>> I PERSONALLY HATE TAKING ANY
UNDERS THAT IF IT'S JUST ONE, I
DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS, MAN.
I DON'T.
I REMEMBER WHEN HOPPE GAVE US
THE UNDER 5 1/2 POINTS FOR
PATRICK BEVERLEY.
I WISH WE COULD'VE LIVED TO
THAT FIRST PARLAY.
BUT HE MIGHT MAKE ONE.
>> WHAT IS PAT?
IS PAT BEHM ON THERE?
>> IS PAT BEV ON THERE?
I DON'T THINK PAT BEV IS ON
THEIR.
>> HE'S STILL SUSPENDED.
>> LET'S SEE.
>> WE COULD DO THAT.
WAS HE ON THERE?
HOLD ON.
WE ARE JUMPING TOO MUCH.
LET'S SEE WHAT HAS WESTBROOK
ACTUALLY HIT PER GAME FROM
THREE?
>> LET ME LOOK, I GOT YOU.
WE GOT K STREET SAYING
WESTBROOK THREES OVER, WHICH IS
NOT -- IS A CONTRADICTORY
BECAUSE -- HE'S 29 ON THE YEAR.
>> STEVE UP NOW SAYS HE'S
ROCKING WITH WESTBROOK OVER
ONE.
JUST GOT TO MAKE ONE.
>> I THINK HE COULD MAKE ONE.
>> I FEEL LIKE HE CAN, TOO.
>> HE SHOOTS THEM.
I'LL TELL YOU THAT MUCH.
>> LAST GAME HE ONLY SHOT ONE.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT, BUT THE GAME
BEFORE THAT HE SHOT FIVE, THE
GAME BEFORE THAT HE SHOT FOUR.
>> AND THE TWO GAMES BEFORE
THAT, HE SHOT ONE.
>> IF HE'S SHOOTING THEM --
>> THIS IS TOO VOLATILE.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THIS.
>> I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THIS
EITHER, GUYS.
I'LL BE HONEST.
>> WHAT DO WE HAVE IN THERE
NOW?
>> GIANNIS 30.
>> MIDDLETON WITH 15.
>> DO WE HAVE DRAYMOND IN
THERE?
SOMEBODY SAYING FREMONT OVER 5
1/2 REBOUNDS.
DID WE VISIT THAT EARLIER?
>> WE TALKED ABOUT THE ASSISTS.
>> WE CAN GO BACK.
>> SOMEBODY SAID DRAYMOND OVER
ON THREES.
>> THEY JUST WANT TO LOSE
MONEY.
>> WE WANT REAL TAKES IN THE
CHAT.
>> DO WE WANT TO FADE
WESTBROOK'S POINTS?
IT'S 13.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
>> PEOPLE ARE SAYING DON'T DO
WESTBROOK, AVOID ANYTHING
WESTBROOK.
>> THAT'S FROM FRESH PRINCE.
FRESH PRINCE 1986.
>> COME ON, GO WITH YOUR GUT.
I WOULD SAY NO.
>> I SEE ANOTHER MARCUS SMART
OVER 11 1/2.
ARE YOU GOING TO SELL US, RYAN?
ARE YOU GOING TO SELL US OR
WHAT HE'LL DO WE HAVE TOO MUCH
FROM THAT GAME?
>> NO, WE ARE SPLIT EVEN RIGHT
NOW.
WE'VE GOT AUSTIN REEVES, WE'VE
GOT JAYLEN BROWN AND THEN WE'VE
GOT MARCUS SMART.
I PERSONALLY WOULD BE MORE -- I
DON'T KNOW, I LOVE MARCUS
SMART.
I THINK ANY MARCUS SMART PLAY,
WHETHER IT'S ASSIST OR POINTS,
IS PROBABLY A GOOD BET.
I'M JUST TRYING TO DECIDE WHICH
ONE IS THE BETTER ONE.
AND HOW ABOUT THIS?
WE'LL ADD MARCUS SMART IN
THERE.
LET'S DO 10-PLUS.
LET'S DO 10-PLUS POINTS.
LET'S DO THIS.
>> YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE CARPAL
TUNNEL BEFORE THIS SHOW IS
OVER, GOING BACK AND FORTH.
>> I ALREADY DO.
PLUS 772.
I THINK WE CAN BUY DOWN ONE OF
THE OTHERS.
>> SO THE ONE BUYDOWN THAT
EVERYONE WAS TALKING ABOUT WAS
MOVED GIANNIS  30 TO 25.
>> OKAY.
I AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF THAT.
>> WE'VE STILL GOT KHRIS
MIDDLETON?
>> YEAH, I'M WITH THE KHRIS
MIDDLETON TAKE.
I LIKE -- I AGREE WITH YOU
GUYS.
I THINK WIGGINS BE OUT IS GOING
TO HELP US.
>> DEFINITELY.
IF THIS NUMBER DOESN'T GO DOWN
SUPER CRAZY, MOVING THIS FROM
30 TO 25, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> KIND OF FEEL LIKE WHAT IF WE
MOVE DOWN KHRIS MIDDLETON?
>> WE COULD.
15 TO 10.
LET'S SEE WHAT THAT DOES.
MIGHT NOT BE GOOD FOR US.
NOPE, NOT GOOD FOR US.
>> I'M COOL WITH THE 15.
I LIKE THE 15.
THAT WAS A REAL STRONG TAKE
THAT WE GOT EARLIER, SO NOW WE
GOT SOME SUPPORT. J HERNANDEZ
SAYING YEAH, 25, DARIAN SAYING
25 IS GOOD, AND READ SAME 30,
TOO HIGH FOR SHOW.
WE'RE IN A GOOD SPOT RIGHT NOW
AT 568. WHAT DO YOU GUYS THINK?
SHOULD WE GET AN OPINION?
>> I THINK NOW IS THE TIME FOR
THUMBS UP AND THUMBS DOWN IN
THE CHAT.
LET US KNOW, THUMBS-UP YOU'RE
RIDING WITH IT, THUMBS DOWN,
YOU WOULD LIKE US TO CONTINUE
TO CHANGE.
>> YOU'VE GOT TO READ IT FOR
THEM.
READ IT FOR THEM SO THEY KNOW
WHAT THEY ARE THUMBS UP AND
THUMBS DOWN TO.
>> GOOD CALL.
GOOD STUFF.
JAYLEN BROWN TWO-PLUS MADE
THREES.
AUSTIN REEVES OVER 8 1/2
POINTS.
MARCUS SMART 10-PLUS POINTS.
GIANNIS 25-PLUS POINTS AND
KHRIS MIDDLETON 15-PLUS POINTS .
>> THUMBS-UP OR THUMBS DOWN IN
THE CHAT, AND LET'S SEE.
I KIND OF LIKE THIS ONE, AND I
LIKE IT FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS.
I THINK WE TEASED DOWN A NUMBER
FOR GIANNIS.
KHRIS MIDDLETON, I THINK WE ARE
GETTING SOME PUSHBACK BECAUSE
HE LEFT THE GAME WITH A
SPRAINED ANKLE.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO DEAL
WITH INJURIES ANYWAY, BUT THE
REAL TRUTH  IS HE CAN EASILY
GET 15, ESPECIALLY WITH WIGGINS
OUT.
I SEE NO PROBLEM WITH HIM
GETTING TO HIS MID RANGE AND
POTENTIALLY GETTING TO THE LINE
BECAUSE THE GUYS THAT ARE
REPLACING HIM DO A LOT OF
HACKING.
I KIND OF LIKE THIS ONE.
>> WHAT ARE YOU SEEING IN THE
CHAT, GREG?
ARE YOU SEEING THUMBS-UP OR
THUMBS DOWN?
>> A LOT OF THUMBS-UP, SEEING A
LOT OF THUMBS UP, SO I THINK WE
SHOULD CALL IT, GUYS.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE CHAT, I SEE
A LOT OF THUMBS-UP.
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE PUTTING
THUMBS DOWN ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE
TRYING TO NOT BET ON TNT GAMES.
>> THAT'S A VERY INTERESTING
POINT.
>> WE TOLD YOU GUYS WE ARE
TRYING TO KEEP THIS TNT GAMES
TONIGHT, THEY GIVE US AN EXTRA
BOOST, SO TRY TO KEEP IT TNT
GAMES.
THAT'S WHY WE ARE NOT PICKING
JOEL EMBIID AND ALL THE OTHER
GUYS THAT ARE PLAYING TONIGHT.
BUT I SEE A LOT OF THUMBS-UP.
I DO SEE THUMBS DOWNS BUT LIKE
I SAID, A LOT OF PEOPLE.
>> THE ONLY BEEF IS DON'T TRUST
SMART, DON'T TRUST MIDDLETON,
AND I'M SEEING A LOT OF PEOPLE
TALKING.
NOT A LOT OF PEOPLE, I'M SEEING
A COUPLE THINGS ABOUT BOBBY
PORTIS.
I'M NOT SURE IF BOBBY PORTIS IS
THE PLAY, BUT WHAT'S THE PLAY
THAT YOU'RE LOOKING FOR, WHO
WOULD THAT BE?
LET US KNOW.
>> IS VERY EASY TO SAY NO TO
SMART AND MIDDLETON.
IT'S A LITTLE BIT HARDER TO GET
A SUGGESTION.
I ALSO COULD SEE LAURI
MARKKANEN.
TNT, MAN.
THE GUY PLAYED FOR THE JAZZ.
>> WE KEEP TELLING YOU.
>> IT'S NOT A HARD ASK.
>> MIDDLETON FOR BOBBY.
LET'S JUST GO CHECK OUT BOBBY
PORTIS, SINCE WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT IT.
>> WHAT ARE HIS POINTS?
>> LET'S SWAP THESE TWO.
>> CAN'T EVEN DO BOBBY.
>> IS HE NOT EVEN ON THERE?
>> YOU GUYS KNOW I JUST SAW, GO
BACK DOWN, RYAN.
JONATHAN KUMINGA --
>> INTERESTING.
>> SNEAKY, SNEAKY LEG. WHAT IS
THAT?
9 1/2.
JONATHAN KUMINGA HAS BEEN
BALLING GUYS.
HE HAS BEEN BALLING.
I KNOW WE HAVE VIBES ABOUT THIS
PARLAY.
>> I DON'T HATE IT.
I THINK IT'S A PLAY.
I ALSO WANT TO REMIND PEOPLE
THAT DONTE DIVINCENZO HAS A
NARRATIVE PLAY TONIGHT.
ALL HE NEEDS TO DO IS MAKE TWO
THREES.
HE DID PLAY ON THE OTHER SIDE
BEFORE, SO THAT'S SOMETHING I'M
PLAYING SEPARATELY.
SO JUST WANTED TO THROW THAT
OUT THERE, BECAUSE I LOVE A
GOOD NARRATIVE.
>> I WAS ALSO GOING TO BRING
UP, I LOVE A GOOD GRAYSON ALLEN
PLAY.
>> IN ALL HONESTY, I LIKE DANTE
D VINCENZO BETTER THAN KHRIS
MIDDLETON.
>> REALLY?
>> SIX POINTS.
>> IT JUST DEPENDS ON HOW MUCH
BURN HE GETS, THAT'S REALLY IT.
>> HE'S GOING TO PLAY.
NO WIGS, HE'S GOING TO PLAY.
>> M BROWN ANDERSON SAYS WHO'S
GUARDING MIDDLETON ON THE
WARRIORS?
MIDDLETON FOR 15.
MIKE S818 SAYS THUMBS UP ON
BECOMING.
>> YEAH, KUMINGA IS A REALLY
GOOD PICK.
I'M TELLING YOU GUYS, KUMINGA,
HE'S SITTING AT 10 POINTS.
HE'S BEEN OVER THAT IN HIS LAST
THREE GAMES.
THAT'S A REALLY GOOD PICK.
BUT YOU HAVE A POINT WITH THIS
DANTE D VINCENZO PICK.
LIKE SIX POINTS AGAINST HIS
FORMER TEAM?
>> ITS TWO TRIPLES.
>> IF WE ADD IT, DO WE WANT TO
TAKE OUT GIANNIS?
>> NO, WE ARE LOCKING IN
GIANNIS.
GIANNIS IS DEFINITELY GETTING
25.
>> SO ARE WE TAKING OUT CHRIS
OR ARE WE TAKING OUT SMART OR
REEVES?
>> REEVES IS LOCKED.
>> REEVES GOT TO STAY.
REEVES GOT TO STAY.
I THINK MIDDLETON IS UP FOR
DEBATE, IN MY OPINION.
>> LET'S TRY AND SWAPOUT
MIDDLETON, SEE WHAT WE GET.
>> BETTER ODDS.
>> OKAY, THIS COULD BE THE
DECIDING FACTOR RIGHT HERE. WE
WENT FROM 5 1/2 TO 1 TO ALMOST
6 1/2 TO 1. SO READ IT BACK
OUT, LET'S SEE WHAT KIND OF
VIBES WE GET, THUMBS-UP OR
THUMBS DOWN.
>> HERE WE GO, JAYLEN BROWN,
TWO-PLUS THREES, AUSTIN REEVES
OVER 8 1/2 POINTS, MARCUS SMART
10-PLUS POINTS, GIANNIS 25-PLUS
POINTS AND  DONTE DIVINCENZO,
THE ITALIAN STALLION, OVER 5
1/2 POINTS.
>> I LIKE IT, MAN.
>> PLUS 659.
SO IF WE WERE TO DO THE PROMO,
IT IS $25.
YOU CAN WALK AWAY WITH 154.
>> RYAN?
>> YES SIR.
YES.
>> DON'T PUT IN KUMINGA.
>> INSTEAD OF YOU?
>> INSTEAD OF D VINCENZO.
>> BROTHER.
>> JUST SEE WHAT IT IS.
>> IT'S GOING TO BE HIGHER.
YOU KNOW IT'S GOING TO BE
HIGHER, IS WHAT IT IS.
>> BEFORE YOU DO IT, WE ARE
GETTING THUMBS-UP FROM THE
AUDIENCE.
>> THIS IS PRETTY UNANIMOUS.
>> THIS IS PRETTY GOOD.
>> DROPPED THE MONEY BAG
INSTEAD OF THE THUMBS-UP.
ZIGGY, THREE THUMBS-UP.
>> THIS LOOKS GOOD, BOYS.
>> I LIKE THE D VINCENZO.
>> HOW ABOUT THIS?
LET'S LOCKING THIS FIVE LEG OR.
THIS IS VALID. AND THEN LET'S
GO BACK PERSONALLY AND TOSS TWO
MORE LEGS IN AND REALLY CASH
OUT.
HOW IS THAT?
>> WE COULD LOCK IT IN, BUT ALL
I'VE GOT TO SAY IS WHEN KUMINGA
GET HIS 10 POINTS AND IF DANTE
DOESN'T GET HIS SIX, A LOT OF I
TOLD YOU SOS.
>> I'M JUST PUTTING THAT ON
RECORD.
>> I THINK WE LOCK IT IN, BOYS.
>> WHAT ARE WE TALKING ABOUT,
GREG?
THIS IS THE PEOPLE PARLAY.
THIS IS NOT MY PARLAY.
>> THIS IS THE PEOPLE'S PARLAY.
>> YOU DID REMIND HIM EARLIER,
ALSO.
>> YES, THAT IT'S NOT MINE.
>> THIS CAME FULL CIRCLE FOR
US.
>> I COULD HAVE EASILY COME
INTO THE SHOW AND REMINDED
EVERYONE.
>> GO LOOK AT THE COMMENTS
RIGHT NOW.
LOOK AT THEM SAYING YES TO
KUMINGA.
>> ONE OF THEM SAYS YES.
TWO OF THEM.
J-ROD URMAN SAYS AR, THUMBS
DOWN.
SO WHICH ONE ARE WE TAKING OUT
THEN, GREG?
>> THAT'S ANOTHER ONE.
THAT'S ANOTHER PERSON THAT SAYS
YES TO KUMINGA.
I'M JUST SAYING --
>> MAX PFEIFFER SAYING THE
VINCENZO IS BETTER.
THIS IS WHY I LOVE THIS.
THIS IS SO GREAT.
>> I LOVE IT, BUT ALSO, WE HAVE
NO CONSENSUS EVER.
>> I HONESTLY THINK BOTH OF
THEM IS GOING TO HIT, DAY
VINCENZO AND KUMINGA.
>> LET'S JUST MAKE IT A SIX LEG
PARLAY.
WHO IS GOING TO TELL US WE
CAN'T?
>> CAN WE?
SHOULD WE?
>> CURRENT YOU ABOUT -- RYAN, I
THOUGHT YOU WERE ABOUT GETTING
RICH.
>> ON ABOUT GETTING RICH BUT
THIS IS WHEN WE GET IN TROUBLE.
THIS IS WHEN WE'VE GOT A SIX
LEG AND THEN THE SIXTH LEG
DOESN'T HIT.
>> WHAT IF IT HITS, THOUGH?
THEN WE ALL LOOK LIKE GENIUSES.
>> I'M NOT AFRAID OF GREATNESS.
I'M ADDING A LEG.
WHY NOT?
>> ARE WE ADDING KUMINGA THEN?
>> ARE WE ADDING KUMINGA, YEAH,
THAT'S WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE.
>> THEY WANT US TO ADD KUMINGA.
CC SAYS PLUS 1000 WITH KUMINGA,
I'M WITH THE MONEY.
THEY WANTED. THEY WANT IT.
>> THEY WANT A RIDE.
>> CINDY SAID LET'S GET RICH,
SIX LEG THAT JOHN, WE HAVE TWO
NOW.
>> THIS SMELLS LIKE DISASTER TO
ME.
>> WE ARE BREAKING RULES HERE.
FORGET A FIVE LEG PARLAY.
WE'RE GOING SIX LEG PLUS 1400.
LET'S GET RICH. THE PEOPLE HAVE
SPOKEN.
>> SINCE WE ARE AT PLUS 1400,
REAL QUICK, CAN WE BUY DOWN
JAYLEN BROWN FROM ONE-PLUS TO
TWO-PLUS SINCE WE WERE ALREADY
ADDED.
>> LET'S DO IT, LET'S BE SMART
ABOUT IT.
LET'S BE SMART, GUYS, LET'S NOT
GET CARRIED AWAY.
>> WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT,
SMART?
>> WE SPENT THE LAST SIX
MINUTES GETTING CARRIED AWAY.
>> GETTING CARRIED AWAY, GUYS.
>> THIS IS FUNNY.
>> JAYLEN BROWN --
>> THERE WE GO, IT'S MINUS 2200
BUT STILL KEEPS US AT PLUS
1100.
>> I LIKE THAT.
WHAT'S MARCUS SMART?
GO TO MARCUS SMART.
DON'T WE HAVE HIM?
>> WE TEASED THAT DOWN AS FAR
AS WE COULD BECAUSE YOU
COULDN'T DO ANYTHING LESS THAN
10 POINTS.
>> LET'S GO TO HIS ASSISTS.
REMEMBER HIS ASSIST WAS LIKE
SUPER LUCKY, REMEMBER?
>> YOU'RE A SMART MAN.
>> LET'S GO.
>> WE ARE GETTING SMART ABOUT
THIS NOW.
>> YEAH.
>> ONE IS GOOD. ONE IS GOOD.
>> 8-1 IS GOOD, 25 TO WIN 200.
I'M ALL IN.
>> LET'S GO.
LET'S GO, THAT'S HOW WE THINK
SMART.
WORK SMARTER, NOT HARDER, GUYS.
>> I ACTUALLY LOVE THIS NOW. SO
HERE WE GO, HERE WE GO.
I'M EXCITED ABOUT THIS.
LET'S GO.
AUSTIN REEVES OVER 8 1/2
POINTS, JAYLEN BROWN PLUS ONE
MADE FREE, MARCUS SMART FOUR-
PLUS ASSISTS.
GIANNIS 25-PLUS POINTS.
DONTE DIVINCENZO OVER 5 1/2
POINTS IN A REVENGE GAME AND
JONATHAN KUMINGA, THE GREG LEG
AS I LIKE TO CALL IT, OVER 9 1/2
POINTS.
>> THE GREG LEG. SO IF IT
DOESN'T HIT WE REMEMBER THIS
LIKE IT IS.
>> BUT THE PEOPLE -- I MEAN
YEAH, THE PEOPLE CHOSE IT.
>> THEY APPROVED, THE PEOPLE
APPROVED.
>> I'M VOUCHING FOR IT.
>> FRESH PRINCE -- JAY
HOLDERMAN SAYS HE'S GOING TO
HIT THREE.
FRESH PRINCE SAYS WE ARE GOING
TO BE RICH.
JACK CAM GAVE ME THE MOST
AMOUNT OF THUMBS-UP IN A ROW
I'VE EVER SEEN.
THIS IS SO LOCKIE.
>> I THINK WE ARE VIBING.
THE VIBES ARE GOOD RIGHT NOW.
>> FINISHED THE MILK, TOO,
GUYS.
>> SEE WHAT THE ODDS ARE ON
FANDUEL.
WE ACTUALLY SEE THE ODDS.
PLUS 801.
RYAN, ONE MORE TIME RUN THROUGH
IT AND THEN WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON.
>> AUSTIN REEVES 3 1/2 POINTS,
JAYLEN BROWN ONE-PLUS MADE
THREE.
MARCUS SMART FOUR-PLUS ASSISTS.
GIANNIS  25-PLUS POINTS.
DONTE DIVINCENZO OVER 5 1/2
POINTS.
JONATHAN KUMINGA, THE GREG LEG
OVER 9 1/2 POINTS.
ADDS UP SIX LEGS, ADD UP TO
PLUS 801, $25 TO WIN 200.
IT'S THE TNT PROMO.
IF WE LOSE, IF WE SOMEHOW LOSE
THIS, WHICH I DON'T SEE HOW,
THEN WE GET OUR MONEY BACK.
>> EXACTLY, GET YOUR MONEY
BACK.
TNT PROMO.
YOU PUT IT IN, CLICK, IT'S A
FREE THAT.
YOU GET YOUR MONEY BACK.
>> CLEAT IS SAYING HE'S PUTTING
GAS IN HIS CAR TOMORROW, MAX
FIVE, I LIKE IT, BOYS.
TO VARIOUS COLLINS, WE LIT AND
LOCKIE.
RYAN, SOMEBODY SAYING --
>> THE VIBES ARE HIGH, THEY ARE
UP.
>> THE VIBES ARE HIGH IN THE
CHAT.
THAT'S HOW IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE.
THE VIBES ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
HIGH.
MAKE SURE YOU GUYS TAIL US ON
FANDUEL WHERE YOU CAN NOW ALSO
BUILD PARLAYS LIVE DURING THE
GAME ON FANDUEL.
MAKE SURE YOU GUYS CHECK OUT
THAT FEATURE.
RYAN, LET'S GRADE SOME BETS.
LET'S GRADE SOME BETS BEFORE WE
GET ON UP OUT OF HERE.
DO YOU SEE ANYTHING IN THE CHAT
THAT HAS CAUGHT YOUR ATTENTION?
>> WELL HERE'S A LITTLE CALL TO
ACTION FOR YOU GUYS.
DROP SOME LOCKS YOU LIKE
TONIGHT AND WE'LL GRADE IT.
THE VIBES ARE JUST IMMACULATE
RIGHT NOW IN THE CHAT.
>> THEY'RE THROUGH THE ROOF
RIGHT NOW.
>> FRESH PRINCE, WE ARE ALL
GOING TO BE RICH.
THIS IS JUST BEAUTIFUL.
>> DAN WANTS TO KNOW WHO'S
DRIVING THE BUS TO THE BANK.
THAT WILL BE ME.
I'LL COME PICK EVERYBODY UP.
>> YOU GOING TO BE THE BUS
DRIVER?
>> I'LL BE THE BUS DRIVER.
THAT'S FINE.
>> SEEK LOW TOE SAID GIANNIS 30-
PLUS.
WE HAD THAT IN THE PARLAY.
HOW DO YOU GUYS FEEL ABOUT IT?
>> I LIKE IT.
I LIKE IT  BECAUSE IT COINCIDES
WITH THE PARLAY SO IF GIANNIS
GETS 30 , WE ARE HITTING ONE
LEG OF THE PARLAY.
I LIKE IT.
>> STEVE SAID SHOPPING AT WHOLE
FOODS TOMORROW.
BRAILLE AND JOYCE SAID
CHRISTMAS GOING TO BE GOOD FOR
MY KIDDOS.
>> LET'S GO.
LET'S GO.
>> LET'S GET ON UP OUT OF HERE,
IT'S TIME TO GO GET RICH.
FOR GREG IVORY.
ACTUALLY RYAN -- REVIEW THE
PARLAY ONE MORE TIME, PLEASE.
>> WRITER.
>> COOL, WE'VE GOT TO ASK TO
FOLLOW ON SOCIAL.
WE WILL REPOST THIS BUT FOR
NOW, OUR PARLAY, JAYLEN BROWN
ONE PLUS THREE.
AUSTIN REEVES OVER 8 1/2
POINTS.
GIANNIS 25-PLUS POINTS,  DONTE
DIVINCENZO OVER 5 1/2 POINTS.
MARCUS SMART FOUR-PLUS ASSISTS
AND JONATHAN KUMINGA OVER 9 1/2
POINTS.
YOU ADD THOSE SIX LEGS TOGETHER
AND IT ADDS UP TO PLUS 801 ON
FANDUEL.
>> LET'S GET IT.
I'M FEELING GOOD ABOUT THIS
ONE.
DOING GOOD IN THE CHAT.
RYAN, SCOOPED.
HE GOT THE SCOOP.
>> WE GOT ONE MORE, MAN.
BALLER P 2490.
HE'S PROPOSING TO HIS WIFE THIS
WEEKEND AFTER WE HIT.
WE LOVE THOSE VIBES.
LOVE THAT.
>> WHEN THIS HITS AND YOU
PROPOSE, I'M GOING TO NEED A
TAG SO WE CAN POST YOU ON
SOCIAL.
>> ABSOLUTELY, 100%.
>> SEND THOSE VIDEOS.
WE LOVE ALL THOSE VIBES.
ALL THE GOOD VIBES IN THE CHAT,
I'M FEELING IT.
I THINK WE ARE GOING TO WIN THE
DAY.
I'M FEELING IT.
I'M GOING TO MANIFESTED.
>> ONE MORE IN WE ARE GOOD.
>> KNOW MORE.
>> MB HAS FINISHED HIS MILK.
MY NAME IS GREG.
THAT'S WHAT I CALL HIM, YOU
MIGHT KNOW HIM AS MICHAEL
BOHLING.
NEXT TO HIM IS A MAN WE LIKE TO
CALL ON THIS SHOW, PRODUCER
RYAN.
UNTIL NEXT TIME, FELLAS, LET'S
GET RICH TONIGHT.
PIECE.
[ MUSIC ]